hey welcome everybody it's great to have
you all back here many long-standing
friends of the center and as well as our
faculty and students and it's a real
pleasure to be here today at the finish
line of what has been a terrific project
for much of the last three years here at
the Miller Center our first year project
we're now one year in one week into
president Trump's administration and we
started planning this effort in the
spring of 2015 shortly after I arrived
at the center but it really came from
the Miller center itself there was a
real question when I came in as the new
director here about how we think about
the upcoming three years with a
presidential election looming almost two
years out from when I had arrived and
how we thought about taking the
extraordinary historical archives and
assets that we've built here over the
years at the Miller center Arlen's
scholars and our network of researchers
historians practitioners and current
administration people at the time and
future administration people that's what
the Miller center is and after several
weeks of planning we came back with this
idea got the support of our Governing
Council and started to to build both
human support financial support for the
effort it has been a terrific team
effort that's brought together all parts
of the Miller center it built on some
terrific things that we had done in the
past not just our scholarly work but
things like the war Power Commission
that was done here in the about 2009
which was a bipartisan group looking at
the president's role in the
constitutional system and that kind of
combination of scholarship and former
practitioners was something that we
wanted to inject into this project it
was easy to predict that a new president
any new president was going to face
immense challenges
and we knew that because we had looked
back at presidential history Lyndon
Johnson once said you get one year you
get one year before the Congress stops
thinking about you and starts thinking
about their own re-election no matter
how big a majority you're elected with
they're gonna start thinking about what
it means for them in the next year's
midterm both the midterm primaries that
will start soon and then the midterm
general election and then on the
national security side we saw from
looking back at history that every
president faces a crisis in the first
year and the crisis comes at precisely
the wrong time when a new team comes
into place many of these people may be
very experienced but they don't know one
another and they don't know how to work
together and we saw that in particular
in the Bush 41 administration and Vice
President Dick Cheney who then was
Secretary of Defense T Cheney told us in
his oral history of that administration
we were probably Dick Cheney ken has
this wonderful ability to go from being
very self confident to also being very
self-critical he said on paper we may
have been the best national security
team ever the president and he might be
right the president United States had
already had eight years as vice
president had been the director of the
CIA had been ambassador to the United
Nations vice president Cheney and
Secretary of Defense Cheney had already
been a White House chief of staff and a
senior member of Congress Secretary of
State James Baker had already been
secretary of the Treasury had been a
White House chief of staff Colin Powell
the new Joint Chiefs of Staff had had
already been National Security Advisor
and the list went on and on Bob gates
was the deputy national security adviser
the national security adviser was Brent
Scowcroft as Cheney said we kept teasing
him that he was going to keep having to
do the job until he got it right and he
said we were great on paper until we
were presented with a crisis a failed
coup in Panama and we totally screwed it
up
I was off giving his ID Dick Cheney was
off giving the speech in Gettysburg I
don't know where the hell Baker was
Powell was new in the job and they
didn't hadn't established a process so
what we wanted to do on the project
across domestic and foreign issues was
think through systemically how a
president does the job in the first year
how do they appoint their cabinet how do
they establish those processes that make
an administration work how do they
identify their priorities and move
forward on those priorities particularly
legislatively but even the things that a
president can do by executive action how
do they manage that that very difficult
to miles between the White House and
Capitol Hill and manage those
relationships we heard Jimmy Carter tell
us in his oral history that he was
elected as an outsider he didn't need
the support of his political party or
the lobbying and other groups in
Washington now that sounds actually very
similar to the year that we've been
through and he said President Carter
said because I didn't have those
relationships they felt like they were
on the outside and it limited his
ability to get some of the things done
that he wanted to get done so we wanted
to look back across presidential history
to assess not just the structure of
presidential first years but what the
opportunities and threats for an
incoming president were and to help
shape the understanding of the first
year for an incoming administration for
the public in general and for the
Washington policy community as they
themselves had to plan for this moment
that comes in sometimes every four years
and sometimes as with this president
every eight years
we wanted to bring together researchers
with practitioners and what we were able
to accomplish is pretty extraordinary
looking back on it we had almost 60
essays which are available still on our
first year West website in which today
we're releasing in this book crucible
which is a collection of what we believe
were the best of those essays this book
was edited by Mike Nelson who's on our
panel here today as well as Stephanie
georgakas Abbot our Mike is a senior
fellow with us stephanie is the
assistant director of presidential
studies and Jeff Chidester who was the
director of policy here at the Miller
center when we started the project was a
real designer of the entire effort and
builder of it as well and is now the
head of Admissions and External Affairs
about a mile and a half down the road at
the baton school and we're still
delighted to have Jeff with us and part
of our family we were able to earn
coverage and prominent media outlets
including CNN Fox Times slate NPR The
New York Times The Washington Post more
than two dozen first year project events
across the country Jeff produced a
terrific event at the Reagan Library
including an assembly of previous speech
writers going back to I think at least
the Reagan administration not Carter
right I think we had Reagan Bush Clinton
Bush and Obama that went from Ken
Kuchiki and who is probably you know 40
years out from his job to a UVA and
Miller Center alumni Kyle O'Connor who
was an Obama speechwriter he went from
listening to Lyndon Johnson's secret
oval office recordings to writing for
Barack Obama we were able to do events
in Washington that connected
policymakers and practitioners Mel
Leffler who co-chaired our volume on
national security who is a Compton
professor here at the Miller center
co-hosted the first event in Washington
of the project or the second event we
launched the project and then did an
event on national security in the first
year at the Woodrow Wilson Center and
with that I want to note that we did
events and again Jeff was a huge part of
this events at the historic homes and
learning centers associated with
presidents Washington Jefferson Madison
Wilson Hoover Kennedy Reagan Bush and
Clinton and then finally we work
directly with the presidential
transition teams both for the Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump campaign and
this work helped connect us to the
incoming administration both in the
transition and across the last year so I
want to thank all of them and all of you
for being part of this ride with us and
and I want to start by quickly
introducing the panel a few of whom I've
mentioned already Mike Nelson first
who's a senior fellow with us and who
teaches at Rhodes College Mike took this
work and quickly produced a book with
the help of UVA Press
president Trump's first year which was
recently reviewed I think in the
Washington Post is probably some other
places Mike wrote for the project
including pulling some of the great
excerpts of our oral our oral history
program and one of the first memos
produced for the project Mel Lafleur who
as I mentioned is the Compton professor
and the co-editor of the volume on the
dangerous first year mary kate kerry who
was a speechwriter in the bush 41
administration mary kate and i both
graduated in simply the same time at uva
she went on to work on the bush campaign
I went to want to work on the Dukakis
campaign we know who went farther and
higher as a result of that I was
rearranging deck chairs she was writing
a flight plan
Guillen McKee who is in our presidential
recordings program who's a professor
here at the Miller center who worked on
several volumes including I think the
third volume of essays which was
planning the president's first budget
where he both co-edited the volume and
then also wrote an essay on Lyndon
Johnson's first year in the passing of
Medicare and Medicaid and the lessons of
working with Congress in that endeavor
and then finally Stephanie georgakas
Abbott who co-edited the volume who as
the assistant director of presidential
studies really is the air traffic
controller on all things that happened
here at the center so with that I want
to turn it over to the panel and and
have you all take it away for the
discussion everyone and thank you for
coming I want to start by turning to
Mike Nelson and ask him to step up to
the podium and deliver his remarks what
a great pleasure it is to be with a
Charlottesville audience and with a
Miller center audience and what a great
privilege it was and with all thanks to
Bill Ann thoughtless to be part of this
extraordinary first year project
he has told you a lot about it I want to
tell you a little bit about this book
crucible which has just been published
in which you can actually buy along with
this one Trump's first year if you're so
inclined but you know when you're
editing something you're very very close
to it and you all know the saying about
can't see the forest for the trees but
then months later the book actually
arrived and I was able to see the forest
and I just sort of opened up the table
of contents and as I'm saying in part
because they just elected new members to
the Baseball Hall of Fame if there were
presidential scholars Hall of Fame the
roster of contributors to crucible would
be the inaugural members of the
Presidential Scholars Hall of Fame in
Cooperstown or Charlottesville er or who
knows where it's a wonderful book and
having only written little bits of it I
think I can say that without being
immodest but I'll be immodest when I
tell you about the the project I took on
that came out of my experience because
what the first year the broader first
year project did was kind of immerse
those of us who were involved in it in
the long history of the American
presidency and the long history of the
Constitution of which the presidency is
a part we're talking now well over two
centuries of continuous operation Donald
Trump is the president but he's number
45 it's a long list of those who come
came before and I could go on and on I
won't go on and on but I do want to just
make a couple observations and and maybe
even read you a couple passages from
from my book Trump's first year which
again was informed by and kind of grew
out of the the extraordinary first year
project of the Miller center you know
when Donald Trump ran for president and
when he gave his inaugural address the
theme was America is essentially a day
or two away from the apocalypse but what
I found looking at the experience of his
first year historically was as follows
Donald Trump was fortunate to
take office when he did unlike Abraham
Lincoln he didn't have to deal with the
secession of seven states during the
period between his election and his
inauguration unlike Richard Nixon he did
not inherit a war in which more than
half a million American soldiers were
bogged down
unlike Franklin Roosevelt and Barack
Obama he didn't take the oath of office
in the midst of a massive financial
crisis although the world had its share
of problems when the trump presidency
began they were ongoing not new or
urgent the domestic economy had been
growing slowly but steadily for all but
one quarter of the previous six years
the annual rate of inflation was below
two percent the unemployment rate had
dipped below 5% the percentage of
Americans who regard themselves as
middle or upper class had reached 62% a
greater share than before the 2008
financial crisis the stock market was
already booming and unlike all his
recent Republican predecessors Donald
Trump took office with a Republican
Congress so you look at it that way
Donald Trump was dealt a very good hand
and and honestly you know I'm somebody
who appreciates the significance of the
tax cut bill that was enacted last month
into law but when you step back and you
think what have presidents been able to
do in the past when they had a congress
controlled by their own party one major
piece of legislation and for Republicans
especially a tax cut is sort of like a
six-inch putt right so I think that
history gives us a way of kind of
measuring not the rightness or wrongness
but just kind of the scale of
accomplishments so that's one thing that
historic history I think gives us some
perspective on another is this you know
you think about the last 70 years or so
and and the way in which we have chose
our chosen our presidents and the talent
pool from which we have chosen our
president
and what you see is a trend at work of
which Donald Trump's election was kind
of the latest manifestation so think
about this during the quarter century
roughly quarter century after World War
Two the presidents we elected not only
had experience in government but it was
experienced at high levels of government
in Washington right
senators vice presidents General Truman
Eisenhower Kennedy Johnson Nixon for it
every one of them had sort of built
their career not just in government but
in Washington well no surprise there
right think about what happened before
this period began the federal government
was widely credited with licking the
depression and beating the axis and
Americans had a lot of confidence in the
federal government and then along comes
the Vietnam War and along comes the
Watergate crisis and starting with Jimmy
Carter's election in 1976 we as a
country still want people with
experience in government but not in
Washington right that was part of
quarters appeal as it was governor
Ronald Reagan's as it was governor Bill
Clinton's as it was Governor George W
Bush we were experienced people but
we're not part of that mess in
Washington well if you think the sort of
the next iteration of this trend is
somebody who comes along and says I have
no experience in Washington and I have
no experience in government and that's a
reason to vote for me and that is sort
of where we are now and as people are
looking ahead to 2020 and talking about
Mark Zuckerberg or Oprah Winfrey we may
have more to look forward to in that way
but again it's a way of understanding
the Trump didn't just drop out of the
sky that there's been a long term almost
three-quarters of a century long trend
of which he is kind of the most recent
manifestation
so where did Donald Trump come from he
not the world of government he came from
the world of business but a particular
kind of business he was never the head
of a publicly traded corporation who had
to share power with an independent board
of directors
and shareholders here an essentially a
tightly controlled private company
staffed in part by family members where
he was the boss the point being that he
didn't come out of that sector of the
business world the publicly traded
corporation where you have to learn how
it had a share power with other
stakeholders which might be more
relevant to becoming president in a
constitutional system of government
where guess what you have to share power
with other stakeholders he also came out
of the world of celebrity but a
particular again a particular kind of
celebrity he wasn't a Ronald Reagan who
who made movies and television shows
that were inspiring or dramatic and then
by the way spent eight years as governor
of California he came out of the world
of reality TV I don't know if you if
this is one of your guilty pleasures I
want to ask anybody to confess that they
watched survivor or The Apprentice but
understand what what drives the success
and he was very successful on The
Apprentice for 14 years what drives the
success of those programs is sort of a
guilty pleasure we say in seeing people
fail in seeing conflict so what was the
catchphrase of The Apprentice it was not
you've got the job right it was you're
fired
and so Donald Trump came out of a world
of celebrity but it's a world of
celebrity in which conflict and and
put-downs are kind of of the essence of
things then one other thing about his
background is that nowhere along the way
either through experience or interest or
studying by the way I'm not going to say
Donald Trump is stupid he's not stupid
he's not stupid at all but there's a
difference between stupid and ignorant
I'm ignorant about massive areas of
knowledge like everything under the
heading of science I'm ignorant Donald
Trump happened to take on a job where
knowledge of the history of those who
have come before knowledge of the
constitutional system in which you are
now a leader
might have been helpful but I'll read
you want the last thing I'll read you
from the book is is is maybe the
scariest but also in terms of writing it
the most fun I hope listening to it the
most fun nothing in his long business
career had required Donald Trump to
share power with his absence of
governing experience and lack of
knowledge about American history and
government Trump had at best a dim
understanding of the sharing of power
mandated by the Constitution both
between the state government and the
federal government and between the
branches within the federal government
examples of his ignorance not stupidity
examples of his ignorance abounded a
week before the election he oddly
promised that he would convene a special
session of Congress as soon as he was
sworn in even though Congress is always
in session when a new president is sworn
in Andrew Jackson Trump said quote was
really angry about what he saw happening
in regard to the civil war with Jackson
died 16 years before the war speaking of
Abraham Lincoln to a Republican audience
Trump said most people don't even know
he was a Republican right does anyone
know well every Republican who has ever
thought of himself or herself as part of
the party of Lincoln knows he was a
Republican Frederick Douglas Trump Trump
declare it as if speaking of a living
person Frederick Douglass is an example
of somebody who's doing an amazing job
and then maybe a little more distressing
and less kind of at a July 8 meeting
with House Republicans Trump professed
his devotion to the Constitution I want
to protect article 1 article to article
12 go down the list there are 7 articles
not 12 much less a longer list after
mentioning William McKinley to a crowd
in Youngstown Ohio
he wondered does anybody know who the
hell he is well President McKinley's
birthplace is 12 miles from where Trump
was giving the speech weeks after
Hurricane Maria racked the Virgin
Islands Trump referred to the president
of the Virgin Islands which like all
American states and territories actually
has a governor the president of the
United States is the president of the
version my favorite just in terms of you
know laugh to keep from crying sometimes
but my favorite is when and of course
let me say this Trump has been the
equivalent of Franklin Roosevelt and
John F Kennedy in these ways each one of
those two presidents took a new form of
communications media and mastered it
right FDR the fireside chats radio John
F Kennedy the press conferences the
debates television Donald Trump social
media right social media as a way of
communicating his thoughts directly to
us sometimes in interesting ways as you
might expect from a reality television
star he's been great at sort of
attaching catchphrases that are negative
fill in the blank all of you this is us
like a single log blank Hillary blank
Ted all right New York Times failing
news fake all right we all remember this
stuff that's pretty amazing what we
don't have are like the equivalent the
two-word phrases if I were to say blank
healthcare blank infrastructure right in
other words this is somebody who again
it's the reality TV world but
nonetheless extremely effective
especially in solidifying the base of
support as he's already gotten not so
much expanding that all expanding but
it's solidifying but my favorite
incident of a Trump is when you know the
North Korean government for years they
put out these wild statements about how
about the evil Americans an evil
president and all previous presidents
have been like yes I'm not going to
stoop to that level right until Donald
Trump was accused by the North Korean
government of being an old lunatic and
his reaction was not to having been
branded a lunatic but he took offense
that haven't been branded as old I
thought that's there's something to be
learned from that I'm going to stop
right there because I'll guarantee that
this is the worst talk you will hear
this afternoon even though it was pretty
good because these folks are just the
rock stars of the afternoon but thank
you
[Applause]
now Leffler to talk about foreign policy
and national security I'm always
delighted to follow Mike long ago Mike
and I were colleagues at Vanderbilt
University and so I learned a lot from
him then and I still love listening to
him so he knows how to say things in a
really evocative luminous compelling way
that makes us see realities so I also
want to thank Bill and thoughtless and
Jeff Chidester for sort of engage in
asking me to be part of this project on
on the first year it's been
extraordinarily worthwhile for me to do
this so let me tell you a little bit my
role about my role and some of the
implications of of what we derived from
studying the lessons of the first year
of five previous administrations so we a
group of very renowned scholars looked
at the first year of the John Kennedy
administration the first year of Reagan
the first year of George HW Bush the
first year of Bill Clinton and the first
year of George W Bush and interestingly
there was a lot of consensus about why
things go wrong during the first year
let me tell you the things that we came
up with very quickly very succinctly
things often go wrong the first year
because of an absence of coherence
strategy because of poor process and
flawed teamwork things go wrong often
because there's a distracted president
who's more interested usually in
domestic affairs than in national
security or foreign policy things go
wrong because of poor staffing
delays and staffing key posts in the
cabinet key things go wrong because of
tension and acrimony between the
executive branch of the government the
chief executive and Congress often
things go wrong because the budget
process is not integrated with strategic
planning and strategic thinking and
there's a gap between them now I don't
need to go into any details just think
about those things and you know that all
of these wonderful qualities pertain to
Trump's first year nonetheless as many
writers have said during the last three
or four weeks when they've assessed from
first year it is significant that
there's been no tragedy
there's been no Bay of Pigs there's been
no 9/11 one really good Republican
foreign policy national security expert
said Trump's first year in some is
unnerving but largely uneventful and we
should be happy although things may get
worse but I think we should assess from
first year why is it unnerving and I
would say it's unnerving because the
failures dramatically exceed the
successes I think there's one
unequivocal success of trumps first year
in terms of foreign policy and national
security policy he's more or less
eradicated the territorial base of Isis
in Syria and Iraq a really noteworthy
accomplishment which was already
underway during Obama's last couple of
years but which the military under trump
has succeeded in accomplishing in ways
that
most people did not anticipate that's
about it I think in terms of successes
let me tell you why this is the way I
look at the rest of the Trump first year
failures he's neither improved relations
with Russia which he said he wanted to
do nor has he constrained Russian
actions in Ukraine or in Syria nor has
he confronted prudent over Russia
Russia's electoral intervention in the
United States as well as in most
European countries president Trump for
all his rhetoric has not stopped
North Korea's strategic advances
president Trump has made no progress
containing the projection of Chinese
military strength into the trust into
the South China Sea and has very done
very little to concern to contain the
expansion of Chinese influence elsewhere
around the globe despite a lot of talk
about Iran president Trump has made no
progress restraining Iran in the Persian
Gulf nor has he either renegotiated the
nuclear deal or improved the nuclear
deal or gotten rid of the nuclear deal
president Trump has made no progress in
the Middle East negotiations between
Palestinians and the Israelis
President Trump has neither renegotiated
nor terminated NAFTA but he has
successfully alienated both Mexico and
Canada president Trump has cast aside
America's leadership in terms of climate
president Trump although this gets very
little attention has failed to redress
America's overall trade deficit in fact
if you look at the statistics of
America's trade deficit grew by almost
11 and a half percent during the first
nine months of the Trump administration
while President Trump has been president
over the last 12 months America's
standing in the world has plummeted the
confidence a new poll by Gallup just a
few weeks ago showed that a confidence
around the world in America has
plummeted by 75% in Germany 70% in
France 54% in Japan only 22% of the
people around the globe think that the
United States today can be relied upon
to do the right thing in a crisis in
comparing American leadership in
comparing global leadership roles people
around the world now place the United
States significantly behind their
confidence in Germany and slightly
behind their confidence in China and
just a tiny bit above Russia that's
what's happened but still none of this
constitutes a tragedy nonetheless I
agree with those scholars who say we
should be worried indeed very worried
and let me tell you why it's because
Trump's America first agenda is truly
a radical departure from the policies
that actually made America great after
World War two so what does Trump stand
for what is what is America first
America first is protectionism America
first is immigration restriction America
first is higher American by American
America first is disdain for
multilateral institutions and alliances
America first is for building up
America's military capabilities and its
nuclear arsenal America first is
unilateralism in terms of American
foreign policy America first is to
support authoritarian leaders around the
world from Putin in Russia to Irwin and
Turkey to [ __ ] in Egypt to 230 in the
Philippines etc that's what America
first is but what are the policies let's
just remember for a moment the policies
that actually made America great for two
or three decades after World War two
what made America first was promoting an
open world promoting free trade lowering
tariffs championing currency stability
supporting multilateral institutions
like the United Nations or the World
Bank championing democracy and
self-determination and freedom and human
rights although not always living up to
those things nonetheless always champ
those things what made America great was
building alliances with like-minded
countries and supporting the principles
of collective security what made America
great was supporting the rule of law
what made occur America great was
building up America's super military
superiority but also seeking to control
the arms race persistently seeking to
control the arms race and keep in mind
broadly speaking big generalization
these were the policies that bred peace
amongst the great powers for the last 75
years no great power war do you know
what an accomplishment that is that's
what made America great we supported
policies that prevented great power war
we supported policies that brought
unprecedented unanticipated prosperity
to all of Western Europe and Japan and
more recently in the 1970's and 80's to
places like South Korea and Taiwan and
Singapore and then since the end of the
Cold War policies that have brought huge
prosperity to large swathes of the
people of China and India and even
Vietnam these were the policies that
brought more people out of poverty in
the last 40 years than in any comparable
era in world history those were the
things that made America great
now Trump's first year has averted
disaster but we need to worry about
America first because it's based on a
zero-sum game of world politics a
zero-sum
you of the world it's based on a
strategy that actually brought world
wars in the first part of the 20th
century and repeated depression that's
why the vast majority of foreign policy
experts not Democratic foreign policy
experts but the vast majority of
Republican foreign policy expects PERTs
oppose the America first agenda because
it's not the agenda that made America
great so all of us all Americans have
good reason to worry about the future
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Mel
so we're now going to turn our attention
to domestic policymaking Indian Keys
gonna assess the last year for us
good afternoon everyone I was a
commenting to Stephanie as bill was
welcoming everyone today how hard it is
to believe that we're here that this is
the final event of our first year
project and it's been an incredible road
for this this Center and it's a trend
astre butte to fill in fullest and
really to everybody who works here
because this truly has been a team
effort and a project that's brought the
center together in ways that it never
has been before he stepped out right now
but in that light it's really great to
have jeff Chidester back here today for
this event I think he's in the back
anywhere there so in any case as
Stephanie indicated my role in this
panel as such as we've conceived it is
to think a little bit about Trump's
first year in the domestic arena broadly
defined when we think about domestic
policy and life in the United States I
guess over the last year we're all
familiar with the chaos and of course
with the strong passions the Trump has
generated what really hits me though is
I try to assess this is the feeling that
Trump and his administration missed an
important opportunity this year that
they missed it for specific and
troubling reasons and that they may not
get another chance at that opportunity
we know pretty well
the general overview of Trump's policy
achievements and failures legislatively
no significant achievements until the
passage of the tax cut in December the
failure to repeal Obamacare or to build
the wall or otherwise change immigration
policy or to pass an infrastructure bill
the tax cut was by any definition a big
win but as Mike indicated this really
isn't much of a legislative return when
you control the White House and both
houses of Congress Trump course has been
active in other areas particularly of an
emphasized executive actions rolling
back as much as he can of President
Obama's regulatory legacy from climate
change to immigration conservatives love
much of this but there's debate or how
much a lot of it actually means lots of
things that were either newly
implemented or actually
implemented all or actions that Congress
had taken and in any case it's
inherently impermanent the next
president can reverse these executive
actions just as easily as Trump took
them reversing Obama's actions Trump has
been notably successful in appointing
federal judges you're actually outpacing
Obama significantly and of course Niall
Gorsuch to the Supreme Court here his
role has clearly been quite significant
I will say as an aside on Trump's
overall impact I was struck by a point
that the political scientist Anil
Dresner made in a recent column that
most of the recent praise of Trump's
record comes from social conservatives
and that conservative policy wonks
people in other words who have to
maintain a reputation we're actually
analyzing the effects of policy have
been far more muted or even critical in
their assessments I think this is
telling I haven't evaluated that person
by person but I was really struck by
dresner's argument on that and who
exactly is praising Trump but back to my
main point today the missed opportunity
what am I talking about whatever one
thinks of Donald Trump his election in
November of 2016
highlighted a crisis in the United
States the feeling among a substantial
segment of the public that conventional
politics and governance have failed them
that their leaders no longer acted in
their interests economic cultural even
regional now we can parse the
motivations of Trump voters in many ways
and people have done that pretty much
hen lessly since the election for
example there's a strongly held belief
on the left people like tonhe C Coates
is the best example that nativist and
racial motivations drove most Trump
voters I certainly think that's part of
it but I think there's more going on and
in any case we need to hold in mind that
multiple things can be true at once when
evaluating a group of voters or even an
individual voter in a particular choice
in a specific election in the end I
think that frustration and alienation
with politics is the overarching reason
the Trump eat out his electoral college
when so on his basis my assessment is
that a year ago Trump had an opera
unity to address this phenomenon in ways
that would have served him well
politically and that might actually have
helped the country but he and his
administration followed a different
course ultimately that is not the fault
of the congressional Republicans or the
fault of the Democrats it is on the
president how do I get to this from my
essay for the first year project of
course as bill mentioned I wrote about
Lyndon Johnson's role in the passage of
Medicare and Medicaid in 1965 from which
I derived six general if perhaps not
universal guidelines for how a new
president can advance a legislative
agenda you can find them all in The
Crucible volume now Lobby I'm very proud
and all of the essays the specifics
though of Johnson's particular tactics I
think are less important than the
overall point of the essay which is the
political skill policy and message
discipline and overall vision of the
president can be a crucial even critical
factor in how Congress reacts to a first
year legislative agenda now the
legislative contrasts between Johnson's
first year record granted he had to
first year so we gave him a pass on that
and Trump's is of course striking and it
reflects a lot about Trump's limitations
also those of his administration
specifically an inability to develop a
coherent policy framework designed to
achieve a set of broader goals and then
to guide and when necessary push towards
those ends start with Trump's personal
lack of policy knowledge something like
touched on goes beyond that even
interest in the nuances of policy this
deficit made this overarching goal of
developing an agenda and a vision
difficult the president then compounded
this problem by failing to surround
himself with people who could make up
for his own deficits self knowledge self
knowledge matters a lot in any
administrator and no or less than in
staffing the executive office of the
president said three results I think one
was the decision to open the
administration's agenda with the
ill-advised travel ban which inflame the
opposition
and immediately became tied up in the
courts the second result was the Trump
defer to Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
on legislative priorities out of this
deference came the decision to pursue
Obamacare repeal rather than to focus on
infrastructure I see this as a critical
first-year mistake because it shifted
the administration's focus permanently
away from a serious effort to meet the
substantive needs of its core voters and
to address that underlying crisis of our
politics that I talked about a few
moments ago infrastructure is the key it
would have been popular it would have
made Trump seem like the strong vigorous
can-do president that he claimed on the
campaign trail that he would be it would
have shown that he was following through
on his promise to help those who had
been left behind by conventional
politics not least it would have divided
the Democrats of that I'm pretty well
convinced but Trump was unwilling or
unable to challenge Ryan and McConnell
on the agenda and this pulled him into a
situation where he was pursuing their
priorities rather his own vision or best
interests
once the repeal push was launched we saw
the third consequence of trumps lack of
a coherent agenda and vision even within
the framework of health care repeal
Trump could only fall lacking lacking
even basic comprehension of the policy
issues who new health care policy could
be so complicated
remember lacking that basic
comprehension he could not save the
Republicans from a situation in which
they had not developed a viable
replacement for the affordable care act
and in which they had badly misread the
politics of the issue here's the thing
I've long argued that the Affordable
Care Act is a fundamentally conservative
solution to the dilemmas of our health
care system we can argue the details but
at its core the ACA is a structure that
increases coverage by bringing more
customers to private insurers that is
private companies private businesses and
by expanding a 50-year old legacy
federal program Medicaid that is run
through the states these used to be
conservative principles once upon a time
in the Bush administration a stronger
and more sophisticated version of
President Trump might have recognized
the ACA for what it is and pursued a
more limited version of repeal replace
the individual mandate with a strong
form of continuous coverage requirement
offer moderate adjustments the ACA
subsidy frameworks and regulations grant
more discretion to the states
particularly over cost control and
Medicaid implementation a point there
was explained brilliantly by the way in
first u.s. a bi-racial POC of the baton
school and also Miller Center affiliate
and at that point unleash Trump sent him
out to convince his voters his base that
he was repealing the Affordable Care Act
let him do what he does well sell it
record rhetorically declare victory and
move on to the next item on the agenda
infrastructure and at a more moderate
form of ACA reform rather than repeal
would have done much more to address
real problems and also the alienation
that I think drew voters to Trump it
would also have begun to build a true
governing coalition that might have
redefined our political moment and even
had staying power now I'm aware of a
possible contradiction here arm I'm
arguing the Trump has not acted in any
substantive manner to address the core
problem of alienation the politics was
not working for his voters but of course
those voters his base remain mostly
supportive but this is not actually a
contradiction when we look at the full
record it is the tragic aspect of this
missed opportunity of the first year
Trump has offered his base something a
form of identity projection and that
they believe he represents them and a
politics of grievance against lease
against minorities against immigrants
against protesters against Hillary
Clinton James Comey Robert Mueller and
now Andrew McCabe against all that they
do not like we saw this most blatantly
in
shameful remarks after the events here
in Charlottesville on August 11th and
12th
we saw it reconfirmed in his comments
two weeks ago about he and Africa and
where immigrants should come from this
is the tragedy the choice to act as a
president of a faction to lead an anger
but not to address the real and
substantive issues that led to his
election Trump has governed as Iran
deploying a leadership style that fed
off of and encouraged division among the
public the result is a base that remains
mostly loyal and angry but also a
determines motivated and I think very
likely permanent opposition that simply
can't be won over and perhaps most
notably the political mobilization of
women which I think may be the biggest
outcome in the end of the first year we
will see in November in that point in
this strategic choice are perhaps by his
very nature drop in his first year as
further divided rather than healed the
nation Kenny course-correct
perhaps in part there are rumblings of a
shift towards infrastructure in the
early months of year two and his recent
steps on trade although I find them
highly problematic and they need some
grounds that male identified do you
suggest
possibly a refocusing on economic issues
but the chance for Trump to be a
transformative president to change the
nature of our politics likely depended
on the first year as Lyndon Johnson said
and it is now like that first year
almost certainly God thank you
[Applause]
so finally we'll turn to Mary can't
carry and I just have to remark on her
way up there I have to give the the
shameless plug here for her new podcast
by potterson I listened to the first
episode this morning and it's fantastic
and it's now available on iTunes so
check it out thank you I'd like to
second what Guillen said earlier which
is I arrived at the Miller center as a
senior fellow just as the first year
project was launching and it has been an
absolute joy and I want to thank bill
for including me in all this and it's
it's really been a fascinating
experience so I thought what I would do
is I would start with my essay that I
wrote in August of 2016
about the changing media landscape in in
political news and how the next White
House could capitalize on that and then
talk about so how how that's unfolded
over the course of the first year so so
what I found in August of 2016 was that
much of our news content in politics now
comes to us through news feeds that are
referred to us by friends by our social
streams filtered preferences algorithms
browsers and and often just personal
relationships and that is very different
than how news was coming to us even five
years ago so so my recommendation
amongst many if you want to read it now
it's sort of a somewhat naive but
optimistic set of recommendations
looking back on it now for example one
of my recommendations was that the next
White House should prioritize
influencing traditional news outlets in
its first year a Margaret Brennan who is
a great graduate of the University of
Virginia and is now CBS's white house
correspondent said that we should
emphasize traditional news outlets
because that would emphasize the need
for nuanced analytical coverage of
policies and initiative
because YouTube and snapchat snapchat
she did not say Twitter but she might as
well have could be good at generating
interest but not deep analysis and that
you need traditional media for deep
analysis and I would say that has
certainly been true this year so I had
recommended that the smart move would be
for the white house to increase not
decrease the number of presidential
press conferences as you might recall
the Obama administration towards its end
it was having fewer and fewer press
conferences and I thought that was a
strategic mistake for this reason of
cultivating traditional news outlets one
of the first things that the Trump White
House press team did was expand the
number of seats in the in the White
House press office and include Skype
seats for local media to be able to
participate on a rotating basis at White
House press conferences which was very
smart because more and more Americans
turned to their local media as a more
trusted news source for their for their
political news I also thought that
administration officials whoever won the
election needed to provide content that
matches all these new digital media
platforms so for example videos that
would go on to youtube long-form writing
could go on to LinkedIn more and more
people go to LinkedIn now to read
articles and essays by people whose name
is right next to their their work and so
you can immediately check their
credentials and see if if there's
something you'd like to be interested in
as trustworthy as opposed to just going
onto LinkedIn to find a job there was a
lot of people posting it behind the
scenes photos for example on Instagram
and and live-streaming things on
Facebook live and all of those things
you know you have to match your content
to that particular medium you wouldn't
say do a long long form essay that
you're reading out loud as a YouTube
video 45 minutes long no one's going to
watch that so you have to match the
medium to the message and and then the
last thing I recommended was that
spontaneity and unscripted moments
anything other than it
illustration talking points delivered on
a teleprompter are wildly popular
if so now they are even more wildly
popular that was in fact you know a year
and a half ago trust in government right
now is and was then extremely low and so
I I think that the best thing a White
House can do is try to reach as many
Americans as possible who are not
necessarily visitors to whitehouse.gov
and never will be and so how do you find
those people who are not signing up onto
the White House website to get your
message how do you get your supporters
to share your message to to people whose
minds might be changed in many ways
White House communication strategy is
really old-fashioned public outreach and
coalition building but now it's in
people's hands on their phones as
Guillen said you know White House
strategy in communications is not
traditional under this president by its
very nature and by the nature of his
personality is Mike pointed out and so
that may not change in 2018 what I
wanted to do this today though that's
new and different from that essay is I
did some research into how have things
changed just since the election in terms
of political news and communications and
so let me just share quickly a couple of
statistics and the speechwriting
business when someone has a statistic
that's surprising we call it a cocktail
crasher because it makes you drop your
drink when you hear it so unfortunately
to have cocktails here but in a as of
August of 2017
43 percent of Americans report getting
their news online now that is only 7
percentage points lower than the 50
percent who get their news on television
in 2016 it was a 19 point gap between
those two news platforms television and
online and that has now decreased to a
seven-point gap so what's happened is
fewer and fewer people are watching
television more and more people are
getting on their computers and their
phones to get their ID news mobile
devices are increasingly preferred
nearly two-thirds of US adults who get
their news both on a mobile and on a
computer
prefer I mean sue me are increasing up
from 56% so people get their phones on
lap I mean their news on laptops and
telephones now the mobile news use grew
the most between people ages 50 and 60
for young people were already there but
now older people are turning to their
phones for more news two-thirds of
Americans get at least some of their
news on social media again driven by
substantial increases among older
Americans Twitter saw the largest growth
in 2017 just since the election up 15
percentage points the number of
Americans who are on Twitter now had the
largest share of users of any social
media platform who report getting their
news from Twitter seventy-four percent
of people on Twitter are getting their
news from their the so so big picture in
the United States we have a record high
in terms of the number of people who are
getting their news from social media
whether people are trusting that news is
a different question but we are not
number one in the world we are number
one in terms of the percentage of our
older population that's getting their
news off social media and we are number
one number two excuse me for getting
their news online
that's all courtesy of pew the other
thing that struck me in this research
was that as I said earlier we are not
number one in the world for the
percentage of people who get their news
from social media ahead of us in terms
of advanced industrialized economies
South Korea Canada Australia and Sweden
all have higher percentages of their
population getting their news from
social media
South Korea 20% more South Koreans than
Americans are using social media several
times a day that is shocking to me
amongst emerging and developing
countries the following countries more
people are getting their news off social
media than the United States
Lebanon Arjun
Gina Vietnam Turkey Chile and Brazil so
we are at 39 percent of our population
and as I said South Korea is at the top
57 percent what this shows me is that
there is a tremendous opportunity in the
coming year for President Trump to use
his global reach because obviously there
are more people in other countries who
have access to president Trump's Twitter
feed than Americans are using so far I
think most people would say that his use
of Twitter has been divisive and at
times very polarizing but if he were to
change the tone of it he could do
tremendous good in terms of changing
America's image abroad and I think
that's a tremendous opportunity for him
in the coming year as you look at what I
would call the difference between
teleprompter Trump and Twitter Trump I'm
a I'm a former speechwriter for George
HW Bush and the the difference to me is
is quite jarring at times I did a little
research there's something called Trump
twitter archive calm on the internet and
it has all of the tweets he's ever done
since taking office he has issued
roughly 2,500 tweets over the last year
and on this Trump Twitter archive you
can type in words to see how many tweets
had those words the most that I could
find was under fake news 153 times 98 in
second place Russia and then there are a
number of other words that are you know
various third fourth fifth place number
three that I was not substantive but I
just think is funny
because it's become a catch phrase in
our house is a sad exclamation point and
and he finds the things sad exclamation
point as varied as the Oscars football
playoffs whether Bob Beckel should be on
Fox News global warming and the Russian
investigation so so if you want to sort
of see the lighter side of Trump's
Twitter feed lid you can google sad
exclamation point the flip side though
is this is affecting his approval
ratings and just 26% of 1,500 Americans
polled by the
economists said that Trump's use of
Twitter was appropriate so the majority
think it's not appropriate by the end of
his first year in office the hill
reported that he has spent about 40
hours on Twitter if you took the time
for those 2,500 tweets a staggering 59%
of those polled said they disapproved at
the president's near daily tweets to his
45 million followers I do think he's not
going to get off Twitter I think he
realizes that this is a direct pipeline
that he will not walk away from and it's
a bigger following on Twitter than it is
the number of people who watch the
nightly news anymore
general Kelly his chief of staff was
asked last week about this and you know
at last week it was how he has at times
undermined his legislative strategy by
going onto Twitter and contradicting
whatever the White House strategy is
general Kelley responded he often asked
me hey I'm thinking of reinforcing
whatever the message is with a tweet
what do you think general Kelley would
say absolutely sometimes he doesn't ask
me that he doesn't have to ask me that
he is his own man in this regard and he
feels very very strongly that he is able
to reach the American people out in
Peoria in Montana in central Wyoming
through his tweets because he does not
feel that he's getting a completely fair
shake from the media and I think most
observers at least on my side of the
aisle would say they can understand why
he thinks he's not getting a fair shake
so my hope that you know as a
speechwriter is that his tweets will
start to parallel his rhetoric in his
speeches and and his legislative agenda
despite the best efforts of his speech
writing staff who I think are doing a
very good job I think there's a
tremendous opportunity in the coming
year for him to try and build coalitions
and as Mike noted there's an opportunity
not just to solidify his base but to
expand it to change people's minds and
to broaden the governing majority in
this country so I so I think this coming
year given these numbers hold tremendous
opportunity for him if he chooses to
take it so on that note
I guess we'll take questions right Thank
You audience Q&A but before we do I want
to press Mira Kate on on one piece of
her first-year essay and I need to read
this because I just found it so striking
when talking about the changes in
technology and the fact that more and
more Americans are getting are taking
news from not just the internet but
using their mobile devices increasingly
she notes if it wants to win its first
year the next white house must master
these trends from the start in order to
build trust and support among voters if
not the new administration risks being
left behind by the increasingly media
savvy electorate so I'm curious Mary
Kate in an excerpt where you note that
the White House must master trends that
both build trust and support among
voters how do you position Trump here
because in one regard as you noted he's
mastered this right he's mastered the
use of social media he knows what to say
he knows who he's talking to
but on the other hand what's the effect
on public trust yeah I would have to say
the whole fake news phenomenon is it's
not surprising to me because the numbers
have been there for a long time the
Trump is not necessarily the cause of
this in some ways he's the symptom of it
the the eroding public trust in the
media has started a long time ago before
he ever came on the scene the same pew
research that I was citing on on social
medias use does touch on people's trust
in traditional news sources and the u.s.
this is fascinating to me that the u.s.
is one of the few countries now where
the governing party supporters are less
satisfied with the news media then our
non supporters so in this country that
would mean Republicans only 21% of
Republicans feel that the news media
covers politics fairly fifty-five
percent of Democrats believe that the
media covers issues fairly that is the
largest partisan gap thirty four
percentage point difference in the world
there's only two other countries where
the governing party mistrusts more than
the non governing party so the second
country that does that is Israel which
is understandable to me Australia is the
third and those are the only three the
the striking number of news sources that
are trusted local media is the highest
national news coverage second friends
and family third social media those are
all in the 70s and 80s percentage of
people who trust him social media only
5% of those polls will trust the
information from social media
last year it was 4% so they leaped from
four to five percent one year so that is
shockingly low and I think that explains
why he thinks it's okay to continually
pound the the fake news naming reporters
by name naming networks by name I
thought the the fake news Awards was
ill-advised I'm glad it came from the
Republican Party instead of from the
White House but I did not think that was
helping things for either of them to be
doing it but certainly for the president
in the middle of the government shutdown
to be worrying about that I thought was
a misplaced so in the interest of time
we'll open it up to audience Q&A so
Alfred has a mic in his hand and if you
have a question for the panel please
raise your hand and let's take we'll
take two questions at a time and wait
please for Alfred to come with the mic
so we'll start up here
this is really a question for Miss McKee
I totally agree that Trump's failure to
deliver on his promise of doing
something about infrastructure is
deplorable and for all of us not just
Trump's base I think frankly deferred
maintenance of bridges and roads is a
ticking time bomb I'm gonna have another
bridge collapse in one of these days but
in terms of the base at just the other
night I heard a union boss on television
he might have been from Illinois who
began by talking about the promise
uncarrier that there was this very you
know ostentatious trumpeting enough of
Trump success and in persuading carrier
to stay and not to you know fire all
these people but he said since then of
course that that particular company has
gone and you know fired put something
like vomited people out of work what was
interesting to me in light of your
comment is that he didn't talk about
Trump's failed to come through on
infrastructure he talked about Trump's
failure to keep American companies at
home and keep them from going going
abroad so I I wonder in LA is is is that
comment do you think an outlier or is it
does it sort of represent the feelings
of because he was specifically being
asked whether the Trump voters were
disappointed by his performance in that
respect probably is an outlier yeah I I
think they I wrote a little bit about
the carrier episode when it happened
I guess year and a half ago well not
your half-gay totally 2016 and my sense
then and now is that it was an effective
short-term strategy in the sense of oh
wow he actually jawbone this company
into keeping these jobs he's really
delivering for us but that's just not
something that can be sustained from one
company let alone across the economy and
the other aspect is particularly when we
talk about manufacturing jobs there
forces here that are just bigger than
any presidents and two
put that much focus on your capacity to
retain a particular sector of employment
that faces huge headwinds is a very
risky move and you can the upside of
guess is that he can claim every good
jobs decision that that happens but in
terms of that specific fairly you know
low to medium skilled manufacturing it's
gonna be really hard to sustain that in
the United States regardless of who the
president is and he's in a position
where I think for people like union
members there's an expectation that he
would deliver on that at least to a
degree and that and that water them a
certain right upfront you say that Trump
has mastered social media the only thing
I've seen him do a lot of his twits
tweets that was intentional I'm sorry
but I don't see him doing much in any of
the other social media certainly not
Facebook or well I don't know what all
the others are but I know I haven't seen
him on any other so could you speak to
that let's take another question before
we serve thanks to all of you for your
amazing comments today they say the old
adage is you won't you never get a
second chance to make a first impression
so presidents unless they have these
oddities where they come in and the
carry out of an ex president's term
usually don't get a second chance to
have a first year so my question is this
we know we have the State of the Union
address coming up very soon to our four
presenters today if this president
called you into the Oval Office and Mary
Kate would have had an experience like
this but this president calls you into
the Oval Office and says ask you a
normative question what should I say to
the American people what one thing would
you tell me to say to the American
people in this upcoming State of the
Union what would you
tell him okay yeah why don't we start
with the Twitter question I agree with
you that it's been overwhelmingly on
Twitter that he's been active in social
media and again a missed opportunity to
use these other platforms to reach the
people who would never go on to
whitehouse.gov and that to me I
understand him wanting to do things
differently than Obama and and rolling
back some of the Obama agenda but there
were there were tactics that Obama used
that I think Trump would be wise to
follow up on for example on the White
House website the Obama administration
had a videographer that followed the
president everywhere and had behind the
scenes videos and photos and things that
they would post on this White House blog
and they were all kinds of people who
would write on the White House blog who
were various surrogates for different
policies or you know you'd have somebody
from the Labor Department writing about
unemployment or whatever and and I think
that gave reporters a lot of places to
go it gave people things to share with
their friends they could send to people
who were interested in those things and
that seems to have stopped I went on the
White House website the other day I
couldn't find I think the White House
blog has stopped and I wanted for this
presentation to talk about the speeches
that the President had given to talk
about the difference between the number
of speeches he's given and the number of
tweets he's issued for example and on
the White House website speeches are no
longer separate as a thing that you can
click on and scroll through it simply it
says like statements and papers or
something like that you click on it
speeches are mixed in it's a hundred and
eighty-six pages long and you have to go
page by page looking for anything that's
listed as a speech I thought oh there's
got to be a faster way I shoot my friend
an email and the White House speech
writing staff and I say hey can you tell
me how many speeches the president gave
in his first year and she said she
immediately wrote back as it's sorry we
don't have that
and I thought how can the how can that
nobody be taking you know count of that
so so they're doing things very
differently from the Obama
administration and and I certainly you
know disagreed with many of the Obama
policies but I I also think there were
some tactics that they used that I'm
surprised cut got stopped and and I
think there's an opportunity to bring
those back and try and reach some of the
people outside of his base and start as
I said you know changing minds and
broadening the coalition Mike what would
you say about the State of the Union
well as far as Trump relying on Twitter
I think to to advantages that he derives
from that as opposed to doing Facebook
and doing Whitehouse Govan all the other
things that one could do and that is
first of all you know where to look to
find out what Donald Trump thinks you
don't have to go from one site to
another its Twitter is the way he's
gonna he's going to express his thoughts
and the short punchy 140 character 280
character whatever it is it's short and
that seems to be a medium in which he's
very comfortable that the the quick
punch or counter punch so I don't I
don't blame him for doing what he's most
comfortable doing and and and making it
simple for people to find out where he
is as far as the State of the Union a
great question Barbara Perry last year
he gave a State of the Union which most
people thought was like a regular State
of the Union address that a regular
president we give and people were
commending him for that and then in
coming days as if you know he just got
bored with being praised for that sort
of quality it was bang bang bang tweet
tweet about this tweet about that tweet
about the other thing so I think the
advice I would give is what it whatever
STUV all know what your agenda is for
the coming year right this is an annual
speech it's meant to kind of set the
agenda for Congress and the rest of the
government for an extended period of so
know what you want to accomplish during
the coming year and then don't just give
the speech but give the speech as part
of a coordinated strategy of
articulating the message and then
reinforcing the message
but I just don't think that takes a kind
of reining in of one's own tendencies to
to do what Donald Trump
apparently does every day and that is
get up in the morning turn on the cable
news talk react to it and reaction goes
straight from here to his right index
finger to his phone to us and because
it's reactive because it's what he sees
or hears on Fox and Friends or or the
Morning Joe or whatever it's not part of
a coordinated effort to not only
articulate a message but to reinforce
that message in subsequent days
something else I mean the the the praise
that Donald Trump gave for a State of
the Union address was kind of the praise
you give for like your eight-year-old
grandson who does you know who draws a
picture and you think oh that's so
beautiful when Donald Trump gives a
speech from a teleprompter it's so
obvious he's just reading from a
teleprompter right this is not something
he's comfortable doing and so in
addition to Twitter I think is his main
form of communication with the American
people is to have these campaign style
rallies in states that he carried in the
election and I don't even know if he has
a text but if he has a text it's just
there to I don't know why it's there
because it's stream-of-consciousness and
he feeds off the the support of his
crowd as in Twitter
he's Twitter is not his effort to reach
out to the people who don't support him
nor are his speeches his communications
are to solidify the base that he already
has and in that sense I think you know
he's sunk he started out with 46% on
election day he had no honeymoon period
which was in part his fault but also in
part the Democrats fault and then it
sort of got down below 40 and and since
then it's been pretty flat so people
chose up sides really early
in the Trump presidency they chose up
sides whether they were former against
them and what he's done so far at least
again in the absence of crisis in the
absence of a recession who knows what
will happen when those kinds of events
occur which they're bound to but
consolidating that 35 to 39 percent is
something he's been able to do and
that's enough that is enough to keep the
Republicans in Congress scared enough
that they don't do what they would like
to do frankly and that is defy him and
get Mike Pence in there but they're
afraid to do that because they know that
the voters who will pass judgment on
them in a primary election are 35
percent of the whole country but they
are 70 percent of the people who vote in
a Republican primary so as long as he
can keep that base solidified which he's
doing through Twitter and doing through
these stream-of-consciousness rally
style speeches he's probably okay for
the coming year but boy these midterm
elections in November I think may be the
most consequential in history if he
loses that Republican Congress if he
loses the Republican Senate when there
are 26 Democratic seats on the ballot
and eight Republican seats and still
loses which is conceivable you go
state-by-state that could happen
I suspect that Republicans in Congress
will smell blood in the water and and
and head for the exits but that's
getting way ahead of her we'll come back
next year right Trump second year I
think if he called me I'd say something
like mr. president I know you love the
attention of the American people and I
know a quick way for you to garner
support among 60% of the American
population tell them you can step down
the media
seriously though if he if he if he
really did call me let's say he really
did call me I I would say because I know
Stephanie you think it's likely that he
will otherwise you wouldn't have asked
this or Barbara you wouldn't invest this
profound question if you didn't think it
was something that was likely to
happening so no I would say you should
say to the American people that I know
my first year has been deeply divisive
and I know that America's prestige has
been reduced around the world I think
those things are very unfortunate and
I'm dedicated I'm going to dedicate this
new year to redressing these trends and
this is what I'm going to do ABC DNA
that's what I would tell tell them to do
Pete hang up I mean he you know when he
doesn't like what he's hearing he sort
of ends immediately so at our panel last
week we asked mark short who's president
Trump's legislative director if he had
any hints for us on what the president
might say in the State of the Union
content wise and he said yes
it'll be infrastructure and immigration
would be big parts of the speech so so
as far as my personal advice goes though
I agree with you Mike I think he's he's
uncomfortable on a teleprompter in
general his speeches are not the problem
he has really not gotten in trouble for
anything that's been in his speeches
unless he ad-libs the UN for example he
had Rocketman that he had lived into the
speech the speech writers are giving him
material that is very good and very
standard Republican issue rhetoric but
you can tell from his delivery that he's
not crazy about being on a teleprompter
and so to those
I would suggest that the speech be as
short as possible his speech last year
was one hour on the dot that was shorter
than the trend over the last few
presidents has been longer and longer
State of the Union addresses and yet as
we saw in this research fewer and fewer
people are watching television and so I
think in order to meet the audience
where it is I would keep it shorter with
a shorter attention span of the people
who are watching second I would say most
speech writers especially for State of
the Union addresses the fun part of the
speech is writing absolutely shameless
applause lines and trying to see how
many times you can get people in the in
the room to stand up and give a standing
ovation if the the partisan side of
doing that is to try and get one side to
stand up and get the other side to sit
on their hands but if you were being
public spirited and a unifier you would
want as many times as possible where
both sides stood up and so I would say
in these polarized times we would want
as many applause lines as possible where
both sides could stand up and agree on
something and then the third part is the
fun part also of the State of the Union
for me is I believe great speeches are
made of great stories and the only way
to get some stories into the State of
the Union are those people who sit up
with the first lady in the gallery and
some presence in the past have used
those as an opportunity to score
political points and have people in the
in those seats that illustrate their
partisan agenda the better ones I think
if you if you're as old as I am and
remember the Lenny Skutnik diving into
the Potomac River he was the first one
President Reagan ever did to start this
tradition and and Lenny Skutnik was a
civilian who was sort of a first
responder and save lives
diving into the cold Potomac River and
pulling people out and I think we've had
a tremendous number of natural disasters
this year things like that where every
day of Americans have have done heroic
things and those are the kind of people
I would put in the gallery this year so
that everybody in the room can salute
them and stand up together and I think
it's an opportunity to be unifying and
draw on what's great about our country
that's the one thing about you know when
I was a kid if the president gave a
speech on television well there was
nothing else on right the three networks
they're all showing the president over
time think about the coming of cable so
you didn't have to watch broadcast
network with the president you could
watch ESPN or whatever and then along
comes remember video cassette players
you could put in a movie or sone and
since then it's just and so the audience
that the president's been able to
command just by giving that kind of
speech or any kind of speech has gone
down which to me is fascinating about
Donald Trump because getting our
attention has not been his problem right
we Cable News essentially went all Trump
all the time during the campaign not
because of any sort of political agenda
but because they saw their ratings going
up and therefore their advertising
revenues going up and it hasn't stopped
so we put you know a political scientist
o presidential give a serious speech and
then reinforce your points that's the
kind of thing we don't watch frankly
what we'll watch is when the day after
the speech you know we sort of wind or
the fact that the president gives a long
policy speech and then what basketball
player will he attack through Twitter or
something like that then we we've got to
make we're back on his wavelength so I
this is a guy who was 71 years old I'm
68 so I kind of go no I kind of know
what that's like he's been successful
certainly in his own mind but I think by
most measures he's been successful at
everything he's ever done in the
business world the entertainment world
and then lo and behold he runs for
president first entry-level job for him
this is not a guy who's gonna change his
ways no matter how good our advice is
it's just not so I think we got to
accept that the likelihood that that
he's going to grow the office will make
the man or
you know he will learn on the job or
something like this is the guy we
elected and he hasn't changed one bit
yeah and you have the last word Oh keep
it brief I don't think an election has
ever been won or lost in the State of
the Union address and I don't think this
one well either hey I guess I would
probably say similar to Mel that he
should think through his strategy really
over the next three years is he trying
to motivate that and sustain that base
or is he trying to reach out a little
more to broaden it and that and the
speech should reflect that choice thank
you all I think bill has one thing to
add but I want to note too please join
us in the anteroom outside mic Jeff and
I will be signing books so feel free to
join us well I want to close by just
giving a lot of thanks to a lot of
people that were involved in this in
addition to all of the people here I
think pretty much every scholar at the
Miller center contributed in some way
has it pretty much everybody on our
communications team our development team
our administrative team this has been
truly an all Miller Center project and
it's been terrific to see the whole team
working together and that extends to our
Governing Council we created also a
first year Advisory Council for the
project that Mary Kate was part of it
was a bipartisan team of former
administration officials from both
Democratic and Republican
administrations it was a little like
Noah's Ark every time we found one we
had to find another to go with them to
to partner and pair with them Barbara
Perry is the head of presidential
studies really helped coordinate this
and again Jeff Chidester who's back in
the back and Stephanie really played air
traffic control and then the last
programming note is people have been
asking what comes after first year and
it's not second year what we are going
to be launching here in two weeks or a
week and a half on February 5th is our
new research undertaking which will take
us forward for the next three years or
so and we're calling a presidency at the
crossroads and it will look back across
presidential history at great moments
going back to the found
all across Jacksonian and the civil war
ii-era
and in the 20th century periods like the
progressives and World War one the Great
Depression in World War two in the 60s
how civil rights in Vietnam and in the
current moment where big domestic
challenges couple up with big
international challenges that face the
president and how different presidents
have reimagined the office for better or
worse how they've taken the path that
they're on and then considered turning
right turning left or just continuing to
go straight or maybe sometimes making a
u-turn and so we're calling it
presidency at the crossroads and we'll
be kicking that off on February 5th
Barbara Perry and I are delighted to
host Jim Lehrer who is on our Governing
Council and will walk with him since he
was there when George Washington was
president actually Jim Jim service and
studying and covering the presidency
actually goes back to November 22nd 1963
when he was a street reporter in Dallas
and was there at Love Field when
President Kennedy's plane landed and
that began a career where he's covered
every president's sense and we're
delighted to have Jim walk through us
some of the big decisions he's seen both
in his lifetime but also back across
presidential history so we hope you'll
join us on the late afternoon of
February 5th and with that I want to
thank the panel and thank all of you and
we'll see you in the back room and sign
signing books
[Applause]